bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo en compagnie
de michael chamas bonjour je n'ai qu'à
elle l'actualité de la semaine a bien
sûr été dominé par la crise grecque et
son irruption dans le g20 de cannes
georges papandréou
sommés de respecter les engagements de
la grèce sous peine de se voir couper
les aides prévues
les européens ont détesté son idée de
référendum
le budget de la sécurité sociale adoptée
par les députés cette semaine avec à la
clé 500 millions d'économies aussitôt
adoptée à l'assemblée
aussitôt modifié au sénat la commission
des affaires sociales la trouver un
dijon irresponsables et irréalistes par
l'eau enfin la première grande passe
d'armes entre le gouvernement et la
majorité socialiste du sénat vie
s'échange autour d'une proposition de
loi socialiste sur l'école obligatoire à
3 ans un texte finalement retiré on y
reviendra
et avec nous pour commenter toute cette
actualité évidemment dominée par la
crise européennes alain lamassoure
député européen ump vous siégez pour le
parti populaire hors pair ce que l'on
appelle le ppe vous avez été ministre
délégué des affaires européennes et du
budget sous le gouvernement de alain
juppé s'était peu près en 1995 au
parlement européen vous êtes aujourd'hui
le président de la commission du budget
du parlement européen vous le
spécialiste de l'europe pour vous cette
crise était-elle prévisible
le dernier épisode grecs n'ont pas du
tout pas du tout tout le monde était
surpris y compris en grèce puisque le
premier ministre grec
après cet accord laborieusement négocié
et que tout le monde avait jugé positif
le 27 octobre il ya quelques jours fait
une conférence de presse devant ces
médias nationaux présente cet accord
comme historique et inespéré et explique
qu'il va tourner définitivement à y
revenir
voilà la page de la crise de la dette
grecque
et puis trois jours après tout seul il
décide notre décision de caractère un
peu fou danse assez imprévisible par
contre ce que
la persistance de la crise qui n'est pas
une crise de la zone euro qui n'est pas
une crise de l'euro contrairement ce que
disent de grandes voire en france et
rieur qui est une crise de la dette
publique dans 12 15 pays européens mal
géré et qui ont besoin de remettre à
l'ordre leurs finances publiques
voilà c'est smith et lisible cruellement
nationale dans l'union européenne
sa femme certains pays de la zone euro
sa femme des pics ne sont pas dans la
zone euro ça n'a rien à voir et que
l'euro je pense la grande bretagne
lalande doyen la grande bretagne une
situation comparable à celle de
l'espagne et ça tant qu'on n'a pas
trouvé des solutions là et pas trouver
des solutions durables définitive ça
devait recommencer
on peut espérer que maintenant on va
plutôt vers une amélioration et une
stabilisation alors on y revient plus
précisément georges papandréou donc
cette semaine bêtes noires de l'europe
sans consulter ses partenaires aux
européens vous l'avez dit le premier
ministre grec annonce la tenue d'un
référendum dans son pays pour faire
valider le plan de sauvetage
inacceptable pour les dirigeants
européens alors mercredi avant
l'ouverture du g20
georges papandréou est convoqué la suite
est racontée par kathia gilder il est
arrivé discrètement sur la croisette
invité surprise de ce g20 georges
papandréou convoqué en urgence par un
gala merkel et nicolas sarkozy
la séance d'explication a été brève mais
le message très ferme
nous sommes prêts à aider la grèce mais
cela implique que la grèce de son côté
remplisse ses engagements
les décisions prises le 27 octobre sont
les bonnes elles doivent être appliquées
rapidement
l'ultimatum est clair si la grèce
n'acceptent pas le plan européen
elle ne recevra pas les 8 milliards
d'euros que ses partenaires doivent lui
verser avant noël pour l'aider à payer
ses fonctionnaires mais en coulisse déjà
la possibilité de voir le pays sortir de
la zone euro n'est plus tabou
la grèce est à la fois quelque chose
qu'on pouvait surmonter et en même temps
quelque chose dont on peut se passer
mais dans le pays nouveau coup de
théâtre
deux députés du pasok le parti de george
papandréou au pouvoir ont fait défection
il refuse le référendum et demandent des
élections anticipées à la veille du vote
de confiance organisé devant le
parlement le premier ministre grec
lâché par ses propres troupes a déjà
perdu sa majorité
alors alain lamassoure quelle mouche
avait donc pitt les georges papandréou
ne vouloir organiser ce référendum
je ne sais pas je crois que c'est un
coup de folie parce que entre le moment
où ils trouvaient sept accords
enthousiasmant et quatre jours plus tard
le moment où il propose de le le jouer
aux dés par un référendum s'ils ont
consulté ni ses partenaires européens ni
sa majorité parlementaire ni son propre
gouvernement ni sont promises des
finances donc bon il ya eu un problème
personnel
oui c'est enfin c'est une espèce de coup
de poker
moi je ne je n'irai pas très loin dans
l'analyse psychologique de georges
papandréou
je voudrais en tirer essayer d'en tirer
une leçon politique qui dépasse la grèce
nous voyons bien que avec les problèmes
affrontés actuellement et avec
d'ailleurs le nouveau traité européen
qui s'applique depuis deux ans au traité
de lisbonne
le conseil européen les sommet européen
sont amenés à prendre de plus en plus de
décisions importantes y compris dans des
domaines qui reste de compétences
nationales le vent de réformes et il
faut le compléter
il faut le compléter parce que comment
marche le conseil européen
ce sont nos grands dirigeants qui se
réunissent à huis clos qui débattent à
huis clos qui décide à huis clos et qui
après annonce
voilà ce que sera ma politique
budgétaire voilà ce sera ma politique
fiscale
voilà ce sera ma politique sociale nous
sommes des démocraties ça n'est pas
acceptable que le débat ne soit pas
public ouvrira qui au moment
alors moi je propose une vision très
concrets que chaque fois qu'il ya un
sommet euro il y en face un sommet
gouvernementale du gouvernement
économique européen
il y en face un sommet parlementaires
européens avec le parlement européen
mais surtout les parlements nationaux
les délégués par nationaux de manière à
ce que puisse prendre parti et s'engager
dans chaque pays non seulement le parti
au pouvoir le pasok de monsieur
papandréou l'ump en france mais aussi le
parti d'opposition la nouvelle
démocratie grecque où le parti
socialiste en francs un relais
parlementaires immédiates immédiatement
repères que ces grands sujets donne lieu
à un débat public
que chacun prenne position que chaque
dirigeant gouvernementales ou dans le
cas de la france prendrait public dise
publiquement quelles sont les positions
qu'il prend et pourquoi explique ensuite
son vote et cela responsabiliserait les
les oppositions parce que dans cette
crise qui est une crise de la dette
publique
lorsque nous prenons des engagements
lorsque monsieur berlusconi prend un
engagement lorsque monsieur papa de
gaulle lorsque le président sarkozy
prend l'engagement
les créanciers ont besoin de savoir dans
l'hypothèse où les intéressés perdrait
le pouvoir
ça peut arriver à l'occasion d'un vote
démocratique
si l'opposition honorerait ses
engagements vous parlez de silvio
berlusconi a parlé également du cas grec
pour aller au delà
aujourd'hui le prochain problème c'est
l'italie baisse dès aujourd'hui c'est
évidemment l'italie un risque majeur
pour l'italie et donc qui est un région
qui est très intéressant parce que c'est
un risque est plus politique
qu'économique
les fondamentaux économiques de l'italie
ne sont pas si mauvais que ça leur
déficit est même inférieur au nôtre
mine de rien ils ont un endettement
gigantesque lisant l'intensité qui est
détenu par les italiens et qui est comme
ça depuis toujours bon sauf que sauf que
nul ne sait ce que vaut aujourd'hui la
signature de silvio berlusconi contenu
sa situation politique en italie et donc
ceux qui prêtent à l'italie qui sont pas
des spéculateurs
les financiers qui achètent de la dette
souveraine c'est pas des méchants hedge
funds
c'est au contraire les financiers les
plus sérieux les sicav les fonds de
pension les caisses de retraite qui
dans leurs statuts ont l'obligation
d'avoir une majorité de leurs placements
en bons pères de famille et jusqu'à ces
derniers temps les meilleurs placements
les plus sûrs et est considéré que ma
dette souveraine mais ses créanciers ils
ont besoin de savoir si ce qui
succéderont à silvio berlusconi dans
quelques semaines quelques mois en
italie
honorons les engagements silvio
berlusconi le problème se pose
aujourd'hui en france pour françois
hollande et le parti social on va s'y
intéresser à la masso que dit la gauche
sur ce problème et bien sûr le parti
socialiste vous ont pas liées à un
instant ils ont trouvé un angle
d'attaqué ils s'en prennent à la
mauvaise gouvernance de l'union
européenne écouter ses réactions à
l'assemblée nationale quand l'économie
française et l'économie allemande
divergent le couple fonctionne mal et
pour le couple fonctionne mal
l'europe brin que bâle nous assistons il
faut que les dirigeants européens et
singulièrement monsieur sarkozy et
madame merkel comprennent que ce n'est
pas simplement avec des accords
laborieux est tardif sur les finances
publiques que l'on mobilisera le peuple
européen il faudra le faire avec des
perspectives avec du sens à la masso
vous parliez d'un problème pour françois
hollande et de positionnement pour le
parti socialiste cette mauvaise
gouvernance est ce que c'est une façon
finalement de s'en prendre à nicolas
sarkozy une façon déguisée de son prono
président oui bien sûr ils sont dans
leur rôle d'opposant mais j'adore
j'adore l'expression de jérôme cahuzac
président de la commission des finances
lorsqu'il dit bah oui les économies
allemande et française diverge
mais pourquoi elles divergent parce que
en 1998 au même moment il y avait un
gouvernement socialiste en france lionel
jospin à un gouvernement social
démocrate en allemagne gerhard schröder
et qu'au même moment ces deux
gouvernements ont pris des décisions
radicalement contraire du côté allemand
on se retrousse les manches ont fait
plus de plus d'efforts on réforme
notamment la sécurité sociale on va en
parler tout à l'heure l'assurance
maladie l'assurance maladie allemande
aujourd'hui dégage chaque année des
milliards d'euros d'excédent et au même
moment en france
eh bien on baisse les bras on passe aux
35 heures il y à 12 ans la france avait
une balance commerciale excédentaire
l'allemagne était déficitaire
aujourd'hui l'allemagne est la première
puissance commerciale du monde son
excédent commercial dépasse celui de la
chine et la même branche le couple
franco-allemand aujourd'hui dans la
crise que l'on a vécu est ce qu'il a été
un moteur ou un problème il a été un
moteur le problème c'est qu'on a besoin
encore du moteur franco allemand
alors qu'avec le traité de lisbonne on a
mis en place une autorité et même
plusieurs autorités qui sont faites pour
présider l'europe il ya un président
permanent du conseil européen
où est il qu'at-il fait quelle impulsion
at il donné il ya un président de la
commission européenne at il mis des
propositions sur la table et là nous
avons un problème de fond je dirais dans
le fonctionnement des institutions
à défaut heureusement qu'il ya eu le
couple franco allemand
heureusement sinon pour le coup on n'est
pas sorti de la belle quelques retards à
l'allumage quand même tout le monde a
réagi un peu trop tard sur cette affaire
n'a qu
mais si vous voulez la vérité de tout ça
c'est que dans la relation franco
allemande
ça tient pour personne ç'a toujours été
un peu comme ça moi je l' ai vécu du
temps de valéry giscard d'estaing et
helmut schmidt puis du temps de françois
mitterrand et helmut kohl
c'est toujours les français qui
réagissent le plus vite ils ont plus
d'inventivité ils ont plus de créativité
les allemands en l'espèce il freiné
parce qu'à la fin des fins si finalement
les prêts que nous faisons ne sont pas
remboursés c'est l'allemagne qui paiera
qui paiera plus que nous allons toujours
plus réticentes va évidemment mettez
vous à la place du chancelier allemand
où la chancelière allemand qui se dit si
les grecs rembourse pas ses les
contribuables allemands qui vont payer à
la place des contribuables grecs
voilà à la fin des fins il ya un accord
et là où les allemands sont meilleurs
que nous c'est que les allemands quand
ils prennent une décision et qu'ils ont
signé un accord il honore ils vont
jusqu'au bout
parfois nous nous sommes à lui un mot
sur nicolas sarkozy vous avez émis
quelques doutes
par rapport à ses capacités sur à faire
face à cette crise
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vaudou se leurrer
et ou non j'ai pas du tout émis des
doutes sur la capacité de la leaf a pas
de grille au contraire je trouve que
dans toutes les crises internationales
qu'il a eu à gérer elles ne l'ont pas
manqué depuis la première la guerre
qu'elle a oublié maintenant russo
géorgienne pendant qu'il assurait la
présidence du conseil européen
la première crise financière lehman
brothers elles peuvent l'aider dans le
cas de 2012
non là une élection présidentielle ne se
fait pas sur la politique étrangère
par contre il a montré des capacités de
réactivité à la crise une justesse d'
analyse et une capacité formidable de
comptes de conviction le g20 s'est réuni
cette semaine le g20 c'est une invention
de sarkozy dont les américains ne
voulait à aucun prix à la fin 2008
il a confrères q les quais 19 votre
dirigeants mondiaux les plus importantes
de se mettre autour data il a une
capacité de réaction formidable dans la
crise par contre je suis obligé de
reconnaître que dans cette crise
on distingue les pays bons élèves qui
sont bien gérées comme l'allemagne et
les mauvais élèves mal gérée comme les
pays méditerranéens bas la france elle
est entre les deux et la grande question
pour nous français sait de quel côté
voulons-nous tomber ce que le
spécialiste que vous êtes dirais quand
même que nicolas sarkozy reste le
meilleur président après 2012 pour gérer
une crise qui n'est pas loin d'être
terminée incontestablement on va passer
à présent au reste de l'actualité on
commence mercredi par le projet de loi
de finances pour la sécurité sociale
le budget de la sécurité sociale a été
voté ce mercredi par les députés avec à
la clé 500 millions d'économies
le texte prévoit notamment de renforcer
la lutte contre la fraude
en revanche la piste d'un abaissement
des indemnités journalières de congé
maladie a été abandonné à donner un
aspect que les députés du nouveau centre
se sont abstenus lors du vote du budget
déjà dépassé selon le budget dépasse et
c'est d'ailleurs l'argument qui a été
avancé au même moment par les
socialistes au sénat pendant qu'il était
votée à l'assemblée le texte passait
dans les fourches caudines des sénateurs
de la commission des affaires sociales
il n'en est pas sorti indemme c'est
moins qu'on puisse dire la quasi
totalité des mesures a été rejetée
explications de cécile section le projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale adoptée à l'assemblée est il
déjà obsolète au sénat mercredi les
députés ont adopté le budget de la
sécurité sociale
pourtant quelques heures auparavant au
sénat la commission des affaires
sociales à modifier son contenu de fond
en comble les sénateurs de la commission
majoritairement de gauche jugent ce
projet indigent irresponsables et
irréalistes en ligne de mire des
hypothèses économiques trop optimistes
et notamment la prévision de croissance
dépasser car basés sur 1,75 pour cent au
lieu des 1 % annoncés par nicolas
sarkozy
du coup vous des amendements vont être
déposées sur la quasi-totalité des
mesures et la présidente de la
commission ne garantit pas son adoption
au sénat même si nous arrivons à
apporter je vous dis quelques
amendements qui seront votés pendant la
science publique avec mon goût je ne
pense pas que nous voterons et je pense
que la majorité sénatoriale s'abstiendra
sur ce texte mais ça risque d'être
sportif pour pour la science publique un
débat sportif
réponse dans l'hémicycle le 7 novembre
encore une fois la gauche compte
imprimer sa marque au sénat alors alain
lamassoure c'est à l'ancien ministre du
budget que vous n'êtes que je pose la
question est-ce que ce budget de la
sécurité sociale et déjà caduque
indigents et irresponsable dit on dans
l'opposition il faut sans doute adapter
à la fois le projet de budget de l'état
de 2012 et le projet de loi de finances
sécurité sociale aux nouvelles
perspectives de croissance puisque
manifestement c'est budgété des bâtis
sur la base d'une prévision de
croissance de 1,75 pour cent c'était
très précis en 2012 qu'aujourd'hui près
dans la république admet que ça ne
dépassera pas 1% donc sans doute il
faudra les instruments les 1%
je n'en sais rien juste un même soleil
mais il est clair que la croissance
hélas va nous faire défaut et donc il
faut revoir les hypothèses économiques
la réforme d'un système de santé
ça devrait être une des grandes oeuvres
du prochain septennat puisque
l'assurance maladie est toujours en
déficit de plusieurs milliards d'euros
en france ce qui veut dire que nous
faisons rembourser nos grippe et d'un
rhume de cerveau en fait par nos enfants
et c'est un domaine dans lequel il y en
a d'autres
la comparaison franco-allemande est
extrêmement intéressante on constate que
un niveau de santé et services de santé
d'efficacité équivalente l'allemagne
le système allemand coûte infiniment
moins cher et que par exemple pour
donner un seul chiffre
alors qu'il ya 18 millions d'allemands
de plus que deux français
il y à un millier d'établissements
hospitaliers publics ou privés de plus
en france qu'en allemagne vous
l'expliquez comment aux dépenses plus on
rembourse plus en france et pour ça nous
avons même un système qui ne
responsabilise pas suffisamment ceux qui
décident la dépense en allemagne
ils ont choisi un système dit
complètement différent du nôtre je
recommande pas de prendre le site
initialement mais ils ont choisi un
système qui responsabilise qui
responsabilise les régions länder l on
oublie
il ya sur d'équilibré elle
elles sont même en excédent nous nous
sommes en déficit il faut en sortir
là c'est le fameux trou de la sécu il
n'existe plus en allemagne donc la
gauche qui dit un projet indigent
irresponsable irréaliste vous êtes
d'accord avec ce que dit le parti
socialiste ça pique à ses biens au
projet socialiste
ces adjectifs et ce n'est pas un jeu de
mot une saison pareille matar non mais
ce n'est pas une plaisanterie ma part
parce que le projet socialiste a été
conçu il y a 6 mois sur la base de
prévisions de croissance
donc ils aspirent à l'époque ça n'était
pas déraisonnable à l'époque quel point
les recettes sont liées à la croissance
économique de 2 ans et demi pour cent il
faut qu il revoir complètement leurs
voix françois hollande l'a dit lui-même
et jérôme talon renault à voir mais il
faut qu'ils donnent des précisions et
j'espère vous donner un baiser le réseau
pour le projet du parti socialiste n'est
pas sur le budget notamment
mais bien entendu sur le budget d'abord
sur le budget d'abord et je le redis ça
n'est pas moi spécialement qui le
demandent
c'est tout ce grâce à qui la france peut
financer ses fins de mois
son budget national et même sur les fins
de mois de son assurance maladie
c'est à dire les prêteurs les opérateurs
financiers ils ont besoin de savoir si
françois hollande honorera les
engagements pris par le président
français on va trouver 8 milliards
d'euros d'économies pour le prochain
budget on doit faire des économies
notamment peut-être une hausse de la tva
très bonne idée
je pense que nous sommes obligés de
faire une hausse de la tva je ne vois
pas très bien à l'égal du système
allemand comme vous le disais tout à
l'heure à l'égal de ce que nous avons
fait avec alain juppé quand j'étais
ministre du budget en 1995 97 en
augmentait de deux points la tva pour
pour en contrepartie alléger la
fiscalité qui pèse sur les salaires
c'est-à-dire les cotisations salariales
ce qui était favorable à l'emploi et aux
salaires voilà c'est ce qu'on fait
depuis les anglais c'est ce qu'ont fait
les allemands tout le reste de l'europe
nous a évité aujourd'hui le taux de tva
français à 2 le taux principal à 19,6
est inférieure à la moyenne européenne
c'est l'impôt qui rapporte plus
contrairement à ce qu'on dit ça n'est
pas un impôt injuste puisque les
les consommations notamment alimentaires
ou les plus sociales sont frappés au
taux réduit de 5 et demi pour cent et
donc moi je suis en faveur d'une
augmentation sera faveur d'une
augmentation du taux très rapidement est
ce que l'ampleur de notre de notre
endettement n'exige pas quand même à
terme une remise à plat de tout notre
système fiscal
oui oui bien sûr on parle des mesures
mais oui oui mais mais ce qu'ils disent
c'est des mesures sparadrap on attend
leurs propositions de fond parce que
l'idée web va faire payer les riches
enfin il faut quand même savoir que
notre impôt sur le revenu qui a beaucoup
de défauts et payé dans des conditions
telles que c'est 10 % des contribuables
qui payent 70 % des impôts
donc on peut demander un peu plus à ces
10% contribuables mais c'est ce n'est
absolument pas à l'échelle du problème
que rencontrent aujourd hui la france
nous avons besoin d'une réforme
d'ensemble notre système fiscal
alors alain lamassoure va passer à
l'actualité du jeudi le premier gros
clash au sénat entre le gouvernement et
la nouvelle majorité socialiste passe
d'armes dans la nuit au sénat entre le
ps et le gouvernement en cause la
proposition de loi de la gauche prenant
la scolarité obligatoire à 3 ans le
ministre de l'éducation nationale a
tenté de bloquer l'examen du texte
invoquant l'article 40 de la
constitution
cet article stipule qu'une proposition
est irrecevable si elle implique une
charge financière supplémentaire pour
l'état échanges très vifs dans
l'hémicycle les premiers depuis le
changement de la majorité julie du golfe
la proposition de rendre l'école
obligatoire dès l'âge de 3 ans a
finalement été retiré au sénat guerre le
gouvernement avait invoqué l'article 40
de la constitution qui empêche
l'adoption d'une proposition créant plus
de dépenses que des recettes en position
la constitution c'est la loi des lois
c'est la loi suprême
c'est notre règle à tous nous avons donc
un devoir c'est de la respecter depuis
quand avoir la majorité ça constituerait
un blanc seing pour violer la
constitution
cette proposition de loi si elle était
adoptée entraînerait une surcharge de
dépenses pour l'état de 1,3 milliard
d'euros
pour la gauche nouvellement majoritaire
au sénat il s'agit d'un véritable coup
de force politique
une gifle à l'institution sénatoriales
d'autant plus que le texte avait reçu
l'accord du gouvernement pour être
inscrit à l'ordre du jour cette
manoeuvre juridique du gouvernement
montre le peu de cas que le gouvernement
fait du parlement c'est a traduit je
dois le dire la manière dont le
gouvernement méprisent les
parlementaires comme il méprise tous les
élus de notre pays un geste très
politique
les prochaines séances de la haute
assemblée risque d'être animée sur le
millier de l'éducation at il eu raison
d'interdire ce projet de loi nous y
opposer oui bien sûr pour des raisons
financières
oui comment le financer commencée le
moment c'est pas le moment j'ajoute que
ce qu'on appelle l'article 40 est tout à
fait opposable le général de gaulle à
rester une proposition de loi le le
général de gaulle a introduit dans la
constitution de la vème république une
disposition selon lequel un
parlementaire ne peut pas déposer un
amendement ou une proposition qui aurait
pour effet d'augmenter les dépenses de
l'état
donc on ne peut pas se concentrent ou v
la contrepartie sans trouver la
contrepartie bien entendu journée on
peut et on peut le financer par une
contrepartie réduction d'une dépense ou
augmentations d'impôts ça n'était pas le
cas semble-t-il dans cette proposition
de loi des députés européens mais vous
avez quand même un oeil sur ce qui se
passe en france le sénat de gauche qui
met en difficulté le gouvernement vous y
attendiez certainement mais à ce point
là
oui bien sûr c'est normal c'est le jeu
démocratique moi ça ne me choque pas du
tout et je trouve ça très sain et j'ai
une suggestion à faire ou aux sénateurs
à la nouvelle majorité sénatoriale un
des handicaps majeurs de notre pays
je reprends la comparaison est tellement
c'est le coup fantastique de notre
système administratif notre pyramide de
notre couche de collectivités
territoriales nous avons consommé
l'europe l'état la région le département
les intercommunalités et la commune avec
des des doubles emplois dans les
compétences et en face de ça nous avons
même une autre hiérarchie parallèle par
exemple la gestion des fonds européens
que je finance
elle est traitée à la fois par les
régions les départements les
intercommunalités les communes et enfin
ce par le préfet de région le préfet
département de soupe
ces communautés justement on a eu dès
cette semaine au sénat
on est fou et ceci nous coûte un argent
considérable ce qui fait que si l'on
additionne les fonctionnaires de l'état
et les fonctionnaires de toutes les
collectivités locales
la france a autant de fonctionnaires que
toute l'allemagne
alors que l'allemagne à 18 millions
d'habitants de plus il faut mettre le
système forcément j'aime assez cette
réforme territoriale ça et est même un
des grands chantiers alors c'est vous me
devancer nicolas sarkozy et le
gouvernement ont voté la première étape
de cette réforme consistant rationaliser
et notamment à préparer la fusion entre
les départements et les régions et
jaguar jour m'avait ça à plat et mais
j'attends avec impatience les contres
position de la gauche en espérant
qu'elles iront dans un sens dans le sens
de la simplification de la clarté pour
le citoyen électeur qui me comprend
rigoureusement rien et naturellement des
économies parce que nous avons là des
frais généraux de la nation un
gaspillage budgétaire considérable sur
mon vous entende aux tentations de ce
que je suis en ce moment sur le sujet et
bientôt sur le conseiller territorial où
seuls nous français nous avons plus du
tiers de toutes les communes européennes
il y a quatre vingt onze mille communes
en europe dans les 27 pays dont
trente-six mille en france
allez on termine rapidement avec
l'action qui a visé cette semaine les
locaux de charlie hebdo la rédaction de
l'hebdomadaire satirique a publié un
numéro spécial rebaptisé charia hebdo a
été détruite dans la nuit de mardi à
mercredi par des jets de cocktails
molotov
le site internet du journal a également
était piraté un acte qualifié d'attentât
par les responsables politiques un mot
peut être un la maison je partage
naturellement l'indignation c'est
inqualifiable
en même temps faisant attention à éviter
des provocations à l'égard des religions
et notamment de la religion musulmane a
été une
vous allez faisons intense
on a vu ce qui s'est passé au danemark
faisons attention d'autant qu' on ne
fait pas ça envers toutes les religions
personne ne peut se permettre de
caricaturer la religion juive comme en
caricature la religion catholique ou
maintenant la religion musulmane
on sait pourquoi faisons attention il ya
des sensibilités
nous avons beaucoup de musulmans en
france si nous voulons les aider à se
sentir complètement à l'aise en france
dans cette période difficile
évitant les provocations et puis nous
espérons que d'ici quelques années les
musulmans pourront rire d'eux mêmes et
de leur religion comme moins catholique
je le fais de ma propre religion
ce n'est pas tout à fait le cas
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup merci d'être
intervenu avec nous dans cette émission
merci aux nuits nous nous retrouvons non
pas la semaine prochaine pour cause de
11,9 en mai la semaine suivante
bonne semaine
moi